in the year 2022 smartphones are
competing with cinema cameras and gaming
pcs we'll run through a list of the
elite flagship devices and decide which
one of them is 2022's best smartphone
let's dive in
first on the list we have a brand with a
fanbase so loyal you would think elon
musk owned the company if you want to be
simple about it the xiaomi 12 pro is a
solid flagship phone and this after the
spectacular run its predecessor had we
can all recall that xiaomi launched the
first commercially available smartphone
that charges at 120 watts and a phone
with an almost one inch camera sensor
the mi 11 ultra a year after and every
serious device had adopted these
features its new offering the 12 pro
sports a fingerprint resistant glass
black design a 6.73 inch 2k amoled
display coupled with quad speakers that
have support for dolby atmos its
interiors are powered by a snapdragon 8
gen 1 chip that is matched with 12
gigabytes of ram and 128 or 256
gigabytes of storage it's dual sim if
that's your shtick but you might be
disappointed to know that the storage is
non-expandable nevertheless the device
has an excellent triple 50 megapixel
camera system that gives crisp and
natural photos the device itself is
powered by a 4 600 milliamp hour battery
that will get you through a day on full
charge at a price point of 999 dollars
it is definitely worth your buck
oneplus 10 pro
next on the list we have a brand from
china that has stepped up its game ever
since it was first launched in 2013.
oneplus 10 pro the first thing that
attracts people to a brand new phone is
its looks and while the 899 dollar
oneplus 10 pro might not be the best
2022 device it has an incredibly sleek
design but looks are not enough for this
list and that is why the oneplus 10 pro
also has three rear cameras that place
it above the average smartphone its main
ultra wide and telephoto lens that all
come to a whopping 150 megapixels makes
it easy to see what the fuss is about
well it is the incredibly powerful
qualcomm processor the snapdragon 8 gen
1. this processor also ensures that
whatever pictures you take will be
seamless on its 6.7 inch corning gorilla
glass screen but even though this might
be the best device the company has made
it is not the best out there not when
there is the
sony xperia pro i
can you spend 1 800 on a phone the sony
xperia pro i might not appeal to
everyone but that doesn't take anything
from the fact that it is one of the best
camera phones of 2022. in fact the i in
xperia pro i stands for imaging which
pays homage to sony's alpha mirrorless
interchangeable lens cameras let's just
say that the xperia is a phone attached
to a camera it sports an image sensor
that enables outstanding low light
performance and high dynamic range while
its triple 12 megapixels might seem like
a downer to the uninitiated megapixels
mean nothing if your sensor is small i
hope the oneplus team is taking notes
the xperia pro i's rear cameras use
three glass lenses from zeiss and its
main 24 millimeter lens has dual
aperture which allows its user to change
the depth of field more quickly to
create an authentic bokeh unlike the
digital software created bokeh effect
that other phones produce the xperia pro
i is the first smartphone in the world
that records 4k videos at
120fps and still preserves all 120
frames while other smartphones compress
4k video files the pro i ensures you
have 100 control in post-production its
other features include a 6.5 inch oled
display with 120 hertz refresh rate it
runs on a qualcomm snapdragon 888 5g
processor it comes with a standard 12
gigabytes of ram 512 gigabytes of
internal storage a micro sdxc card slot
and a 4 500 milliamp hour battery which
can be fast charged at 30 watts now
while these features sound nice it is
not a balanced device nowhere is
balanced as the
google pixel 6
google is a valuable brand so it makes
sense that they make valuable products
with the pixel 6 it appears they did
just that released in 2021 this simple
looking gadget remains relevant in its
second year priced at a reasonable 899
dollars the pixel 6 pro offers a 6.7
inch oled screen with 1440p wide
resolution that is powered by google's
new tensor chip a first of its kind
custom made processor that rivals
qualcomm snapdragon 888. aside from
powering the phone the tensor processor
also enables a myriad of ai based
customization to enhance features in the
camera speech recognition and gaming the
pixel 6 also comes equipped with 12
gigabytes of ram and 512 gigabytes of
storage but the true star of the show is
pixel 6 pro's cameras which are beyond
impressive remember what i said about
large sensors well pixel sensors are
large and they feature in its dynamic
trio of ultra wide wide and telephoto
cameras its main camera is 50 megapixel
its ultra wide is 12 megapixels and its
telephoto camera is an impressive 48
megapixels its video recording
capabilities are top of the shelf you
can shoot 4k at 60fps as long as you
want without the phone overheating and
it has an 8 megapixel front camera and a
94 degree field of view which means that
you can fit in everyone in your next
oscar-inspired selfie but this efficient
google offering cannot take the crown
because it pales in comparison to the
performance beast known as
the asus rog-6
if you think the asus rog 6 looks like a
sci-fi device that's because it is this
phone was created by a company that has
devoted everything towards creating the
perfect gaming pc and this phone is
meant to be a second cousin it has a 6.7
inch ammo led screen that can play
anything in the highest quality its
processor is an upgraded 5g qualcomm
snapdragon 888 its base ram is 8
gigabytes and its internal storage is
128 gigabytes it has an impressive 64
megapixel rear camera and a mind-blowing
24 megapixel selfie camera since this
device is all about gaming performance
which can cause it to become warm during
extended play the phone bundles a geeky
aero active cooler accessory its battery
is 6 000 milliamp hour and outlasts the
pixel 6 pro very easily with an
impressive graphics performance this
techie device is priced at a comfortable
1050
samsung galaxy s 22 ultra
there is no android device on the face
of the earth that defeats the galaxy s22
ultra this beast has an impressive 6.8
inch screen that sports a 1080p oled
screen with up to 120 hertz refresh rate
and is bright enough to use comfortably
in direct sunlight its oled screens have
rich blacks and vivid colors now the
only bummer that comes with the s22 on
the list is its battery and maybe that
is why it is not the number one on this
list but it compensates for that by
supporting 45 watt fast charging
boosting from zero to a hundred percent
in just an hour the s22 ultra uses the
snapdragon 8 gen 1 chipset which is
currently qualcomm's latest and greatest
processor for android phones it also
comes loaded with 8 gigabytes of ram and
performs better than some other brands
with ram overload the s22 ultra cameras
are on another plane of existence with a
108 megapixel stabilized main camera a
10 megapixel stabilized 10x optical zoom
telephoto a 12 megapixel ultra wide and
a 40 megapixel selfie camera video specs
are also phenomenal up to 8k at 24 fps
recording from the main camera and 4k at
30 or 60 fps from the front-facing
camera the galaxy s22 ultra's top
special feature is easily its integrated
s pen it has improved massively since
the note 20 ultra there's 70 less
latency when using it which means that
you might feel like you're writing or
drawing with an actual pen currently
priced at a hefty twelve hundred dollars
it might shake the bank but it is
definitely worth the buck moving ahead
it is time for the moment of truth the
best phone in 2022 is the iphone 13 pro
max don't act surprised apple has proven
time and time again why they're at the
front of the smartphone race while the
android fan club would argue that the
s22 is a better device it's just not
true and i'll show you why the iphone 13
pro max looks and feels sleeker than
ever before and its signature chunky
lenses give it that retro feel that some
might love it also sports an amoled
screen sprawled over a 6.7 inch display
but the true showstoppers are those
chunky yet elite cameras the iphone 13
pro max packs a trio of 12 megapixel
lenses that include main ultra wide and
telephoto cameras the 13 pro is a phone
for those with an eye for details while
most of the cameras on flagship devices
perform on the same impressive level in
normal or bright sunlight it is in low
light that the 13 pro defeats its rivals
unlike all of the megapixel chasing
android devices apple has stuck with 12
megapixels the same resolution it's used
since 2015's iphone 6s but it's expanded
its sensor to take in more light more
quickly than all other phone cameras the
iphone 13 pro max video capabilities max
out at 60 fps and 4k the 13 pro is the
only phone that offers a cinematic mode
for video that provides a rack focus
effect which means it automatically
switches subjects based on who is
speaking if sony xperia made a phone for
photographers iphone made a phone for
hollywood the iphone 13 pro 4500
milliamp hour battery is one of the best
among smartphones it even lasts two
hours longer than the s22 with its own
a15 bionic processor and with a starting
price of 1099
the iphone 13 pro is the best device of
2022 and there we have it not everyone
might agree with this list but i think
the evidence speaks for itself but what
do you think is the iphone 13 pro max
the best thing since sliced bread or did
i miss it also click the video on the
screen for more videos like this